all right thank you everyone for coming to my talk!
um my name is Jeremy Wagner and I'm a technical
writer at Google for Chrome focusing specifically
on web performance and core web vitals
um I am from Minneapolis Minnesota which if you
don't know where that is um don't worry about
it uh it's it's a place uh I guess you could
say if you ever see a Minnesotan depicted on a
television show they kind of you know sound like
this don't you know and so that's really all you
need to know we're kind of a weird remote place
and the further north you go the weirder it gets
um so anywho I'm honored to be in Seoul my
first time in in not just in Korea but in
Asia which is awesome uh to be giving this talk
about a new responsiveness metric uh that we've
been working on at Google called interaction to
next paint or INP for short so let's get rolling
so before we can get into INP we need to
clarify responsiveness and when we talk about
responsiveness we're really talking about how
quickly a user interface responds to a user's
input you've almost certainly experienced poor
responsiveness it occurs when you interact with
something on the page but the visual feedback
of that interaction is significantly delayed
poor responsiveness makes a page seem unreliable
and this unreliability means that you may have
to tap multiple times on a page element which
can cause multiple unintended inputs as you can
tell in this video or Worse no response at
all so we want good responsiveness because
It gives a sense that a page is reliable
in responding to what we want it to do
so what causes poor responsiveness to
answer that we need to talk about tasks
in order for a web page to provide a user
experience a web browser must orchestrate
a lot of work to do that it uses threads there
are many threads but the most important of these
is the main thread it's where most work occurs
including the work your JavaScript code queues up
hang on each discrete piece of activity on the
main thread is a task and a task is made up of
activity in this case we see that this activity
consists of script evaluation and compilation
now each task takes the amount of time it requires
to complete however if a task takes too much time
it affects how quickly the main thread can
respond to subsequent tasks and when that
happens that task becomes a long task a long task
is any task that it seeds exceeds 50 milliseconds
and the portion of the task longer than 50
milliseconds is known as the tasks blocking time
which is the amount of time that the main thread
is unable to respond quickly enough to new tasks
this is a significant source of poor poor input
responsiveness long tasks can cause pages to
be sluggish and unable to respond quickly to
user inputs when it's vital to remember that
tasks Drive everything that happens on the main
thread and that includes interactions here you
can see that there's a single task that shows a
loading spinner as a result of a key down event
these types of interactions and Far Far More make
up the user and experiences that we use every day
and those interactions need to be fast
because what we want is visual feedback sooner
and that visual feedback comes in the form of a
new frame that the browser that the browser paints
hence the name of the metric interaction to next
paint one way of optimizing work in the browser
is to avoid long tasks too many long tasks
are a user experience problem but more than
that it can also be the accumulation of many
small tasks that can be problematic as well
in either case the important thing to remember
is that there is also time that the renderer
requires in order to present the next frame this
involves some tasks that run on the main thread
such as style and layout calculations maybe even
stuff for request animation frame but there's also
time involved on the GPU and compositor threads to
get the next frame ready to paint it's just that
long tasks are easier to identify in profilers so
they're really a great place to start optimizing
now you might be thinking come on Jeremy why
are we talking so much about tasks task tasks
that's all you're ever talking about well the
reason for this is the event Loop which is
something I won't go into deep detail about but
it is important to know just a bit about it uh
and how long tasks or many small
tasks can sabotage the user experience
the event Loop is a continuously looping task
queuing mechanism run by the main thread it
loops around and around and around and around it
does this until the task until a task is queued up
and when that happens the event Loop will pick up
the task a key up event handler in this example
and when the event Loop has has
picked up the task it processes
it and it pops it off the queue when finished
then if the task causes any changes
to the layout the browser has to do
rendering work to reflect those
changes before the next paint
when that rendering work is completed the browser
presents a new frame which is
the visual feedback from the task
if tasks if tasks don't become long tasks or if
there are a lot of small tasks that pile up in
the queue or aren't a lot of small tasks to pile
up in the queue everything goes smoothly but when
there is too much work visual feedback is delayed
that stuttering janky feeling you get when you
scroll and things just aren't working or like just
animations aren't going as fast as they could be
um and even outright freezing of the browser Tab
and some extreme cases that's a problem imp is a
metric that quantifies a Page's ability to avoid
doing these things this will be a quick rundown
of how imp works but for the full story you're
going to want to read the official documentation
at web.dev inp to get a sense of all the little
nooks and crannies in terms of how it works but
because it is a complex metric and I only have
so much time but I will do my best to summarize
imp is a metric bat observes certain interactions
using the event timing API this API receives an
entry every time the user interacts with the
page and contains timings for those interactions
unlike first input delay imp measures more than
just the input delay of the first interaction if
you don't know what an input delay is don't worry
we'll get there and finally it chooses the single
worst interaction or close to it which is intended
to represent a Page's overall interaction latency
it's a bit more complicated than this so a little
bit more on this in a bit the takeaway from all of
this is that imp is all about the time it takes
for the a new frame to be presented for the
current interaction from the time the operating
system recognizes an input for the browser to pick
up that input for the event handlers that drive
it to run and finally for the time it takes the
browser to do all of the rendering work to show
you the results of that work in the next frame
however imp doesn't measure all interaction
types but it does measure most that drive user
interactions those include keyboard interactions
Mouse clicks and Taps on touch screens it's
also important to call out what doesn't get
taken into account for imp at least directly
this isn't an exhaustive list but just a
few things that are important to call out
hovering over elements with a fine pointer
device such as a mouse don't count towards inp
however however because this is tricky you could
trigger animation work that may affect a soon to
be future interaction think if you hover over
a button that has a hover animation um if that
work is occurring as the user clicks on the button
that may delay the presentation of the next frame
network activity is in fact isn't factored into
the duration of an event for inp however fetch
requests are asynchronous and can have an indirect
effect especially if they land during a future
interaction scrolling isn't taken into account
either however that's no word again however
users can scroll with the space bar so if an event
captures space bar inputs that could theoretically
cue up tasks that may affect that interaction
but the scrolling itself is not considered all
qualifying interactions are recorded throughout
the entire life cycle of the page when the
page is unloaded for a new one the pages imp is
calculated by choosing one of those interactions
for pages with relatively few interactions such as
pages with mostly text and images or just simpler
applications with fewer input requirements this is
often the interaction with the most latency or the
slowest or worst interaction however some pages
may have many interactions before they're unloaded
such a single page applications and Rich apps
like in-browser games and other application types
in such cases we don't want to penalize developers
by selecting what could be an extreme outlier of
interaction latency in cases like these the 98th
percentile of interaction latency is selected
the resulting value is the Page's inp
the idea is that by selecting the worst
interaction on the page or closest to
it you have a value that represents a
Page's overall interaction latency think
of it this way if your imp is in the good
range that is 200 milliseconds or less all
interactions on your page are reliably fast
if your imp needs Improvement or is poor then
it's likely that most of your pages or at least a
decent chunk of them uh all those interactions are
too slow but what does an interaction look like
the first part of the interaction starts with
the user input from one of the interaction types
we just discussed for example say a user clicks
on a button to open a menu when the user clicks
there is a period of time between when the user
clicks and the event handlers begin to run which
is called the input delay this is what first input
delay measures but only for the first interaction
imp measures more than this it measures the entire
interaction and all qualifying interactions which
you'll see shortly now you'll always incur
some input delay because at the very least
it takes time for the browser to receive
the input event from the operating system
but that delay can be increased due to tasks on
the main thread as the input occurs long tasks
in particular if you have a lot of long tasks
that are constantly running on the main thread
or even many small tasks input delays can increase
once the input delay is over the event handler is
responsible for driving the interaction can
run now here we see a set of event handlers
for a mouse click the goal here is to ensure
that those handlers run as fast as possible
you don't want those event handlers to run for too
long because the browser has work to do after that
in order to present the visual feedback the user
needs in order to see that something has happened
once the event handlers finish running the
browser then needs to do rendering painting
and compositing work in order to present the next
frame this is called the presentation delay and
all this work to present a new frame to the user
needs to occur as quickly as possible as well
the presentation delay represents just the
main thread portion of the rendering work
there are a lot of nooks and crannies and how
this takes and how long this takes some of it
is under your control some of it may be and it
gets more complicated a single interaction can
contain multiple input delays event handlers
and present presentation delays for example
here you see a mouse interaction where a frame
is presented after the user pushes down on a
mouse button but then when the button is released
a new batch of event handlers and rendering tasks
must run in order to present additional
feedback as the interaction is finished
in cases where there are multiple event handlers
in a single logical user interaction the longest
event duration of the interaction will be chosen
as the latency for The Logical interaction
now we're ready to talk about how to
optimize for imp when you optimize imp
you're going to want to First measure it and
not just in lab tools but using field data
field data is important because it lets you know
how your website is actually being experienced by
actual users in the field and one way to gather
that field data yourself is to use the web vitals
Library which there's a link in the lower right
hand corner to the GitHub thing and I'm also
posting slides on my Twitter later so if you miss
this don't worry the library exposes methods for
each of the core web vitals but also inp and each
method takes a function that exposes properties
for The observed metric most importantly the
metric name itself Imp in this case its value as
well as the element responsible for it provided as
a selector string by a function in the link gist
now when you've got this field data and you
know which elements are responsible for high
interaction latency then it is time to go to
the lab and start testing these interactions
because it is lab tools that will give you a bit
more insight into why interactions may be slow
now one useful lab tool in Chrome Dev
tools starting in Chrome 106. we can
now rely on the performance profiler to show
interaction details right in a performance Trace
so say you know what interacts or what
element is causing trouble you can test
that in the performance panel and dive right
into that interaction in the call Stacks
for example you can see in the interactions
area near the top of the performance Trace panel
there's an item labeled interaction type click
this means that this interaction counts towards
inp and we can see that we have a long task in
our hand um particularly on the The Click event
it appears and we can see that that that click
event is really running for a long time this
method lets you dive right into what's causing the
delay during processing and gives you some ideas
for how to break up or optimize that work just
a little bit better because this particular long
task quies causes quite a bit of delay in the next
frame being presented and also can affect your inp
UT but if you want something a bit more focused
because the Chrome performance profiler is kind
of a it's kind of a beast on its own it's a
lot to take in you can see interactions in the
new performance profiler in the performance
insights panel in Chrome Dev tools it's a
streamlined version of the performance profiler
we're all familiar with but a bit easier to use
so you've profile an interaction and now you want
to know what you can do to optimize it so what's
next the answer to this is rather complicated
and it depends on your website and for after
all every slow interaction has its own fix but
I'm hoping the following provides you with a
general framework or strategy for getting your
tasks under control so one good piece of advice
developers tend to follow is to split up work into
separate functions and we do this for a number of
reasons such as maintainability readability
and testing it's easier to follow it's easier
to test and we get to isolate work into separate
little discrete functioning units however where
JavaScript is concerned uh because all the work
item functions from the previous code snippet
are executing in the same function the do work
function it will group all of that work into a
single long running task and that's not great from
a performance standpoint because instead of five
little functions just doing all their their own
thing and all their own little tasks you have a
big old task that will block the main thread from
doing new work including work that occurs because
of user interactions this will affect your imp if
users are trying to interact with your website you
need to break this up and one way to do that is to
yield to the main thread which breaks up tasks now
this is sort of a user land homemade yielding
function it uses a promise that resolves with
a call to set timeout and this works because set
timeout will schedule its callback in a new task
now with that yield function you can then yield to
the main thread after every little discrete piece
of work by awaiting the custom yield function note
you don't have to yield after every function for
example if you have critical work that updates
the UI you can yield after those functions to
give the renderer a chance to do that work the
result instead is that you don't have one giant
task that has to run five functions but a task
for each separate function and this gives the
main thread more opportunities to yield to other
things things like interactions or background
work that the user doesn't necessarily see or
care about is this approach been hacky Maybe
but there could be a better solution in the
future one proposed part of something called the
scheduler API is scheduler.yield which will work
much the same way as the promise-based solution
I've shown you but will allow developers to tell
the browser directly if the current task should be
broken up and yield to the main thread at specific
points instead of relying on hacks and I'm excited
for this potential addition to the web platform
as it will give developers a way to break up work
without user land hacks but I should take this
time to remind you of one very important thing
breaking up work still isn't enough on its own
imp is all about time time it takes to present
the next frame if you have a ton of little
tasks that are running all the time or lots
of huge tasks that are blocking the main thread
you can't present the next frame after a user
interacts with a page as fast as you might need it
to you still need to do as little work as possible
another way of prioritizing user-facing work is to
explicitly yield to user interactions with the is
input pending method is input pending is available
in navigator.scheduling dot is input pending and
it returns a Boolean if the user has interacted
with an element on the page at the time that
it is called in this code you can see how the do
work function adds separate functions to an array
of tasks and then within a while loop this code
checks to see if there is a pending user input if
so we explicitly yield to the main thread so that
interaction can take place otherwise we shift the
next task off the front of the tasks array and
then we run it the effective isn't input pending
is evident here we have a large blocking task that
do work kicks off however in the middle of that
task is input pending is used to see if a pending
user interaction is waiting for the main thread
which in this case is brought on by clicking a
button to open a navigation menu when is when
is input pending turns true we yield to that
interaction and allow the browser and the main
thread to handle it but there is more that you can
do and that involves prioritizing tasks when using
this strategy you should think of tasks in terms
of what's critical and user facing and wasn't
in what isn't visible or immediate this figure
shows how browser prioritization works by default
when you leave things up to the browser it
will try to prioritize inputs based on a
system of internal priorities it works pretty
well but sometimes it needs a little nudge
the post-task API currently only supported in
chromium browsers and Firefox behind a flag adds
more flexibility to how browsers can schedule
work most importantly it allows the developer
to schedule work based on a system of three
priorities the first is user blocking which is
for critical work that must run at high priority
think of this priority as best for interactions
that need to be processed as soon as possible
there is user visible which is for medium priority
work that may result in visual changes to the
user interface but maybe isn't strictly critical
and then there is background which is
for low priority work think things like
analytics Collections and beaconing and things
that the user doesn't really see or care about
so let's say you have a bunch of work that doesn't
result in any changes to the user interface
this would be background work the shape of the
post task API allows you to create task controller
instances which take a priority value using one of
the priorities I mentioned in the previous slide
then using the task controller's signal property
we can schedule work using scheduler.post task
according to the task controller's
priority now let's say you run that
work and then the user interacts with the
page to open a navigation menu for example
the background work will run at lower priority
but if the user opens the navigation menu those
background tasks will yield to that interaction
this is an exciting API but even more exciting is
that it's still developing there are discussions
currently taking place about adding finer grain
priorities as well as other mechanisms such as the
scheduler.yield functionality I mentioned earlier
on a final note I feel it's important to
make it clear that imp is a developing metric
the Chrome speed metrics team at Google
is still fine-tuning this metric so some
of what I said in this talk may change but the
fundamentals should still hold true in the future
if you have any questions about imp feel free
to ask me in the hallway or at the after party
I don't know everything but I'll try to answer my
you know to the best of my ability I try my best
um but you you may stop me but I'll try I
will also tweet the link to my slide soon
which you will see shortly on my Twitter
profile at malkata that's m-a-l-c-h-a-t-a
and with that thank you for your time
and hosting me in your incredible and
amazing City it's been both an honor and an
experience I'll always remember thank you